[Music]
[Music]
at the end of game of thrones season 8
we are left bitter and disappointed with
bran stark this 3i raven becoming the
new king of westeros
and now we have a revelation coming from
none other than the game of thrones
showrunners david benioff and dan weiss
that the books will end the same
speaking in the audio commentary of the
season 8 episode 6 that for some reason
is the only commentary episode that did
not air on the game of thrones official
youtube channel
a behind the scenes look at filming the
finale showrunners david benioff and db
wise dropped some huge news about the
books the showrunners confirmed bran
being named king of westeros
is author george r martin's planned
ending for his a song of ice and fire
novels
they said that the ending will be the
same bran stark will be the king
claiming that george r martin revealed
it to them and ultimately that is why
bran ended up on the throne at the very
end of the show around season three we
went to visit george rr martin and he
writes and he kind of figures things out
as he's writing
when we went to visit him back then and
this was while he was still writing
book five he didn't know yet where the
story was going
and he knew a few key things and one of
those key things was that the final king
at the end of the story would be bran
george r martin himself had this to say
about the endings of both the show and
the books
how will it all end i hear people asking
the same ending as the show
different well yes and no and yes and no
and yes
and now and yes george then proceeds to
make three points
then they only had eight hours for the
final season but he will have more space
there's the butterfly effect with
changes from past seasons affecting this
one
there are lots of characters in the
books who never made it to the show
so that changes the entire storyline
quite a bit
george armard also said that the 8th and
the final season of the hbo hit was not
completely faithful to the plot he has
planned
otherwise the show would have to run
another 5 seasons he said
what all of this means is that the
ending and fates of most of the key
characters will be the same
then it will descend into madness bran
will become the king
but it's the journey to this point that
will be entirely different pacing build
up characters
everything up until the end will be
quite different before this revelation
from dnd came out i said in my season 8
episode 6 review video that
i don't think the ending is necessarily
bad as in fact it's how george r
martin's books will also end
as they said multiple times that the
ending will be the same but the journey
to get there will be quite different
and the journey is exactly what was so
disappointing in the show
danny going mad bran becoming the king
and everything else could have been
written so that all of this would make
sense
instead we got a rushed and poorly
written season branding is nowhere near
bittersweet only better
i have no doubt that george r martin
will make all of this make sense
and most importantly it will not be
rushed who has a better story than brand
broken tyrion says and for some reason
everyone accepts it
as a valid argument and they proclaim
bran the king
why would they do that he has no better
claim than anyone else
he doesn't even have the best story
among them and he did nothing of great
significance in the war against the
night king
more like brando useless the reasoning
seemed weak
and the lack of setup is apparent what
it shows us is that dnd knew they had to
make bran the king
but had no idea how to make it happen
had no idea how to write his stories
had no idea how to make him one of the
most important characters in the show
which is actually why bran was not even
present throughout the entire season 5
and which is ultimately why the ending
was bad they failed to deliver bran's
journey to becoming the king
to talk about bran's journey in the
books and how will he become one of the
most important characters we firstly
need to understand george r martin's
mind
every important character and event
martin writes is based on the actual
history
from real events to myths and legends
the entire race song of ice and fire is
inspired by the wars of the roses
a series of english civil wars for
control of the throne
the houses and characters from those
wars are what inspired most houses and
characters in game of thrones
most of the characters have their
historical equivalent some of the most
shocking moments in tv history such as
the red wedding has historical parallels
as well
even some of the most epic battles are
inspired by real historical battles such
as the battle of blackwater
which is based on the second arab siege
of constantinople
where greek fire was used to repel the
invaders as it could remain lit on water
just like wildfire was used so now that
we know george armor uses historical
characters events myths and legends to
inspire his own events and characters
we need to ask ourselves on who is bran
stark based
surely the most important martin's
character must be based on someone or
something as most other things are
well some fans might have guessed it
right bran is most likely based on the
fisher king also known as the wounded
king
because much like bran a known warrior
wounded him
and he is unable to father next
generation to carry on after his death
which is one of the main points bran was
chosen a king to make things even more
interesting
in celtic mythology the fisher king is
derived from the figure of brand of
blessed
and the name bran in welsh is usually
translated as crow
or raven which oddly matches with brain
and him being the three-eyed raven
george r martin once said that the fan
theory got the ending right
and few fans became confident that they
now know which one it is
bran is the fisher king it's a story in
which the king is wounded and then
blessed by divine power
the fisher king is the last in a long
bloodline charged with keeping the holy
grail
much like brain is charged by the
three-eyed raven from the very beginning
by appearing in his dreams as a raven to
come to him become him and
keep the power of the three-eighth raven
on his way to holy land to find the holy
grail
fisher king was encountered by three
knights bran stark on his way to find
the triad raven is encountered by three
threats as well
firstly by the wildings where he had to
work hodor and the direwolves to avoid
being found and killed
then he encountered the man of the
night's watch at crassur's keep
where he was captured but managed to
escape and finally for the third time he
was encountered by whites
in front of the 3 8 raven's cave who
were plays there for one purpose
and it's to prevent him from entering it
and becoming the three-eyed raven
as already said the fisher king has many
similarities with brain
from the characters itself to their
fates and journey and names the
nicknames
bryn stark was always supposed to be the
king he is the only type of monarch
george r martin sees fit to rule the
kind where the king suffers on his
journey
and is almost dehumanized for the sake
of his people
in the show brain rules from the red
keep yet the iron throne is destroyed
in the books it's most likely that brain
will rule from harehole
and the great council where they choose
the king will take place not at the
dragonpit
but at harehole this makes far more
sense in the books given the
significance of herreral succession and
lordship
it was here where the previous great
council was held when all the lords
chose and voted for the targaryen
successor
then king jaehaerys first targaryen was
not certain who his successor should be
carrying hole is located on the shore of
the gods eye the largest lake where the
pact between the first men and the
children of the forest was signed on the
isle of faces
carrick hall is also centrally located
being in the middle of westeros
so i think bran will rule from harehole
not king's landing
one of the big differences george armarn
will make that will lead to bran
becoming the king
is bran playing the biggest role in
defeating white walkers
the long night was not really long in
the show it lasted only one night
bran stark did not showcase any of his
powers have no doubt that the books will
deliver on the horrors that were set up
and the white walkers will not be
defeated in a single night
the long night in the books is the event
that will completely change everything
the others the dragons greenseers and
skinchangers
red priests faceless men and undead of
all types
we will see them all play a big role how
will it lead to brand broken
well bran will play the biggest role in
defeating the white walkers
and i believe that will win him the
throne there's one interesting quote
stannis gives to jon snow in the books
stannis says lord seaworth is a man of
humble birth
but he reminded me of my duty when all i
could think of was my rights
i had the card before the horse that was
said i was trying to win the throne to
save the kingdom
when i should have been trying to save
the kingdom to win the throne
george r martin did said this logic of
true king being the one who saves his
people
and what better king than bran who saves
the realm from the long night
after the war for the dawn people will
look at those who save them as their new
leaders
i believe dany will descend into madness
and die but the books will do it much
better than the show did
i believe jon who will be another hero
of the long knight will be offered to be
the king on the great council
on the grounds of him being not only a
hero but the one with the best claim
but he will refuse just like his great
great unclaemon targaryen did
and will go far north removing himself
from political court
the only and the most important hero
left will be brand broken
and he will be chosen a king after a
long council all in all i believe the
books will make bran's journey to
becoming the king satisfying
and more importantly i believe there
will be clues and hints pointing towards
it but the show gave us only a few that
most viewers probably did not even
notice
one particular moment in the pilot seems
significant in retrospect
camera cuts to young brain during ned
stark's recitation of the execution oath
just as ned says the line in the name of
robert of the house baratheon the first
of his name king of the andals and the
first men
camera cuts to brain whom jon tells not
to look away
it seems they left it purposely unclear
whether we should focus on brain or john
in that shot
that's the tactic the show often uses to
subvert our expectations
for example after heart home it seemed
that the night king was after jon
when in fact it was brand that he really
wanted it seems significant that bran is
also the first person we see targeted by
jaime lannister
the man infamously known as kingslayer
trying to slay this king before he even
becomes one
tyrion approaches brain in season 8
episode 4 at the victory celebration
following the battle of winterfell he
compliments bran's wheelchair
saying it's even better than the saddle
he designed back in season one
according to bran his cherries based on
the one darren targaryen built for his
nephew 120 years ago
bran is talking about darren ii
targaryen known as their on the good
he made the wheelchair for his sister
daenerys targaryen's crippled son
his familiarity with that history
impresses tyrion
who told joffrey back in season 4 that
their own story should be required
reading for any future ruler
quote the lives of the four kings grand
maester kate's history of the reigns
of darren the young dragon baler the
blessed aegon the unworthy
and they are on the good a book every
king should read
in conclusion the game of thrones
showrunners confirmed that george
armard's books will land the same
especially the brand becoming the king
part however this doesn't mean we will
be left bitter and disappointed
just because the show failed to deliver
satisfying journey towards descending
dany going mad bran becoming the king
and everything else could have been
written so that all of this would make
sense instead of being rushed
poorly written and bitter i have no
doubt that george armard will make all
of this make sense
give bran stark a good story a good
journey and make him useful
and make him the most important
character in the long night
i believe it will get a satisfying and
bitter sweet ending in the books
and i really look forward to bran
stark's story thank you guys so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed this video
and if you did please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one peace